the strike against General Motors is
already taking a toll on the country's
largest automaker GM stocks slid more
than four percent yesterday
as more than 48,000 workers walked off
the job some estimates suggest GM is
losing as much as 50 million dollars a
day Dean Reynolds is at a GM assembly
plant in Detroit
Dean is any progress being made good
morning well a source told us that
yesterday's meeting was very tense so if
there is any progress it's happening
very slowly and the workers here told us
that they will choose the picket line
over the assembly line for as long as it
takes so far workers here see little
reason for optimism as the strike enters
its second day the corporation's make a
lot of money right now we just ax apply
General Motors made 8.1 billion dollars
in profit last year Patricia brown has
worked at GM for 34 years you want to do
all the work what do you think about
that they just sit back behind that desk
Union Auto Workers like her are looking
at only 250 dollars a week in strike pay
about 625 an hour GM has proposed over 7
billion dollars in investments more than
5,400 new jobs and wage increases but
union leadership told us only 2% of
workers demands have been resolved since
negotiations began in July a major point
of contention is health coverage
according to an automotive news report
Union Auto Workers pay just 3 to 4
percent of their medical costs and GM's
opening proposal called on them to
increase that to 15 percent automakers
see rising costs and they want some more
contribution from workers Cox automotive
executive analyst Michelle Krebs says
the divide between GM and the Union
comes as the industry faces major
changes how many jobs will exist because
of electric vehicles autonomous vehicles
Automation those are issues of real
concern now GM says its goal quote
remains to reach an agreement that
builds a stronger future for the company
and its employees and that includes what
they call nationally leading benefits in
the health care coverage but GM is
offering few details on that point
Gail alright Dean thank you very much